Okay,
good morning. [clears throat]
The plan for today is kernel
optimization.
Uh we got the end to end system running
a couple days ago.
I meant to be doing a lot more yesterday
on it, but I kind of just crashed. So, a
little bit of time off. Um,
but yeah, let me flip this over and I'll
show the plan for today.
I was working on getting the profiler
set up.
This should get us some output here.
Welcome hermit.
Ignore this. This will print in a
second.
Okay. So, there's our profile.
I mean, so we can see we have we have
all of the uh the kernels in here. Now,
there are a couple things I'm not sure
about. So, the first thing is I don't
know if these are initial setup
or if this is like actual real overhead.
And it's weird to me that somehow
I get 1.539 seconds in CPU total and 1.7
seconds in CPU total here. And it looks
to me like it's getting counted here
somehow, right?
Like this is over 100% CUDA time.
And then this is somehow
Yeah, the profiling is weird. I think
that the easiest thing is just going to
be to look at the um
self CPU and self CUDA MS maybe.
But then wait, why do we have we have
CUDA time?
What is this?
Cuda total self cuda.
Actually, it's kind of nice that they
upg uh updated Grock on this cuz I'm
probably not going to need a lot of
Well, hopefully I'm not going to need a
lot of like code today, but I do need
some stuff answered.
I think it's like going to be
including sub calls
specifically in this kernel
inclusive time. Okay. So we want cuda
salt.
I also I should figure out a way to just
get this mic closer to me so that I can
be
maybe next time I get up I'll try that.
It's difficult for me to get this mic
like so it's not straight in my face but
also so it's close enough.
Play with that.
So here
CUDA time total
average.
Is there a filter
South Cuda time. Total
Let's
because you would want to have I guess
if I Check key averages.
Okay, here this is now sorted.
Perfect.
I would really like to have this thing
filtered.
I mean, just looking at this though,
hang on.
A10 copy.
something weird there.
I suppose though we can start by doing
the fuse scan function.
Okay, so the one thing I have to figure
out here, right, is I have everything in
double precision right now and I need to
not
[snorts] I need to not break training.
I think the easiest thing to do is going
to be
let's do like this.
going to get ourselves open a tab with
Neptune
and we're basically when I make changes,
we're going to track. This is not going
to be a perfect test,
but we're going to be able to track from
this starting point if stuff gets uh
noticeably Whoops.
If stuff gets noticeably less stable.
Oh, and uh let me go answer one message.
Oh, because I have a feeling I'm gonna
have a DM on one thing that I didn't get
to yesterday.
Yeah, this is exactly what we want,
right?
Hey, Muffin, welcome.
Oh, and uh FYI as well. So, I'm doing
I'm going to be doing this all day all
day today. Um but it's just a quick one
hour stream to start and then I grab a
very quick breakfast and then I'm pretty
much on for the whole rest of the day.
And the goal is going to be that by the
end of today we should have a fast
stable solve on breakout and we should
be pushing some impressive numbers.
We'll be able to use these fuse kernels
from Python as well. So ideally I'd like
to have it so that we are at least
faster than the LSTM back end today.
Okay, here it is. Fuse scan forward is
super slow. Did this
Let's just let's just do one thing
first.
just kind of guess
and let's see if I just do this if it
changes.
Those are the expensive ops.
Long day of work ahead. Yeah,
I mean I absolutely just crashed
yesterday. I was going to start on some
of this yesterday and like I like I sat
down for an hour and I just could not
get any work done out of myself. So I
said, "Okay, I've been doing this for
weeks on end. I'm going to chill today
and then Saturday I'm going to get a
full day and then I feel way way better
already.
Not like fully refreshed from one day
off, but like way way way better.
Like I feel like I can actually get this
stuff done today.
it's really never worth it to just push
past the point of your like where you
can see your productivity dropping.
I mean, I've kind of had to because I
had some extra client work this week,
but
okay. So, immediately, look at that.
This is immediately faster
So, I'm going to do the rest of these.
Well, first of all, let's let's see if
this breaks anything training wise.
cuz all I did is I took the most
expensive operations out of um double
precision.
So, I actually kind of wonder if I
needed to.
We'll see this first.
And this still trains.
But I want to go look at the launch
actually
red
and seek size.
Doesn't this seem odd the way that I
have this
Third dim.
Block dim. Threads. How many blocks?
Threads per block.
Let me just try a couple things here
because I think I might just have the
launch ar screwy. Like this should be
faster than it is.
crashing. I see.
Interesting.
thing actually build.
I'm surprised if this is the
It is the same.
Okay.
Hello. What is your setup?
What do you mean setup?
This this is just Neil Vim on Abuntu
with like the local GPU and a bunch of
uh servers with the same setup for when
I need them.
Okay, so interestingly this Where's the
board go? Oh,
hang on. That actually made a huge
difference, right?
Yeah, now we're down here.
Let me make sure that's what happened.
Oh no, I literally just misread it,
right?
Yeah, I just misread it. There's
nothing. There's no point in doing that.
Cool. Got to be very careful with the
profiling.
We have to be way more careful with
this.
This is like a
very very precise workday. I think I
just which is fine. I'm just going to be
in the mood that this is going to take a
while, but it's going to be consistent,
clean progress with like very high
clarity. I think that's a good It's like
a nice rainy Saturday. It's super
overcast.
Good mood for this.
Okay. Now, the only other thing to test
is if this now goes back in time,
in which case it'll just be Yeah. Don't
do XP and D. Oh, don't do Xin double.
So, it's literally just don't do X bin
double.
It's actually none of these other ops
are even slow at all. It's literally all
the time is just in these X.
Let's do used scan
backward kernel.
do I see anything else expensive in
here?
No, I just see this.
Okay, so we had the backwards kernel
was at
Okay, this is now a little bit faster.
This is now much faster.
the still diffuse scan backward kernel
is slow. Let's make sure we have not
broken training.
So this is literally just from um
ditching the I was doing everything in
double precision before because we were
just testing kernel equivalences.
Are we going to hang here?
I don't see how we can.
Uh, no. There's that's got to be H.
I wouldn't be surprised that's something
with the environment.
So, what we're going to do is we're
going to do um
So, we're going to disable our
threadbased back end.
And we're going to make sure we uh are
not screwing stuff up.
It's going to be slow, but it's all CPU
overhead now.
Hey, Zed.
Yeah.
Okay, this is the same thing.
So, we're fine here.
Or is it? Let me think. What's can even
be slow in here?
Well, the easiest way to check this,
right?
and this is just written in a way that's
kind of obnoxious.
well wait if it's max. Then it gets this
and then this gets maxed
double diff.
I think there's something else though,
right? So log one PF Enough.
Okay. So, this one we have to be a
little careful with.
I think let me just take a look at this
manually
because we want to make sure that this
is identical.
There's the same loop.
Uh
so this is the one chunk that is
different.
So then it's saying that this line is
equal to those three lines
up here.
Well, let's let's see if this works. I
think this is the
But if this works, then the backwards
can be done the same.
same time but it works.
And then the fuse scan backwards kernel
here.
Okay.
Max trick with safe exponent. Yeah,
that's what we want.
Okay. So now we have to check this very
very closely because this is ultimately
just replacing some uh some statements
some branching statements that were
redundant.
But the numeric are very very important
to make sure they're identical.
This is the same.
The same
D out val.
Why is this changed?
Wait. D
Okay, so this is fine.
And now this is the chunk that's going
to change.
I think this is the same. I don't know
why it likes to flip my statements.
Greater than zero.
and then this is the
this is the chunk that is different
and it should just be eliminating
redundant statements. So let's see
so this is XF
Okay. So, this is the stable.
Hey, Son of Liberty. Today, we are
optimizing the hell out of our training
loop while keeping it numerically
stable.
Internal optimization most of the day.
Oh, yeah. It's 9:50. I'm going to
breakfast in a few minutes. Um, so for
folks watching, I will be doing this all
day. There's going to be a ton of kernel
optimization. We're going to have Puffer
very fast. We're going to have Puffer
stable today as well. And if that is
interesting to you,
oh, the only fish.
Uh, if that is interesting to you,
check out puffer.ai.
All my stuff is here. Start the GitHub
helps me out a ton. Discord is where all
the dev happens. And you can follow me
on X for more RL content and educational
materials as well. But I will keep going
on this for a few minutes.
Yeah, I'm not sure about this one. Let
me Let's compile this first. We're going
to test if it's faster and we're going
to test if it's stable.
Much better, right?
Much much better.
We're almost to the point where Matt
Mole's dominant
is what we want.
Ultimately, you should always have Matt
Mold be dominant with these types of
architectures if you're doing them
correctly, and they almost never are.
and not stable.
Look at that.
You see, not stable.
So, this tiny little change here
completely broke our training.
All right. Well, I'm going to go go grab
breakfast. I'll be back shortly. I'm
going to try to take a very quick
breakfast. And we're going to be doing
this all day and we're going to have
fast buffer live by the end of today.
And this will all be worth it. Thank you
folks. See you soon. And uh yeah.